the next 10 years it's it's going to get
more interesting Than People realize
right we start the show talking about
the these uh these Twitter files you've
got talk about censorship manipulation
we've got a breakdown of the family but
right now those kids you mentioned that
are addicted to those phones that are
growing up in these strange times 10
years old let's say in 10 years they're
gonna be voting and how do you think
they're going to affect the political
system what's happening to particularly
young girls they go on Instagram they go
on Snapchat they go on Tick Tock and
they get depressed when they don't get
enough likes on their posts views on
their videos and it's causing a massive
spike in depression alongside kovid and
all the crazy masks that that's
happening we are going to have two
generations gen Z and Alpha and the Next
Generation and the next they're going to
be so negatively impacted by this I fear
that you know I I hope that we're headed
towards something better right when we
get these exposes on Twitter and the FBI
it's it's shining a light in the
darkness it's sending a signal to people
that Victory Is Possible Republicans
take the house maybe we'll see some
changes but when you start thinking
about demographics and what's happening
with the young people it may be
inevitable that as the older generation
the Boomers and the older Gen X start
aging out retiring they're not voting
they're passing on we lose that level of
stability despite look I think the
greatest generation was just that I
think the boomer generation has some
issues gen xers have a little bit more
Millennials have a lot more gen Z is
going to have way more and it's just
this Cascade effect of generations
getting worse and worse and worse I fear
that for all for all the issues we can
complain about with Boomers
when the boomers are are gone it's gonna
be apocalyptic you're like we we need
that level of stability among them
despite the the criticisms the younger
Generations have same thing is true for
Gen X Millennials are a psychotic
generation it's split down the middle
between woke insanity and then you've
got classically liberal to conservatives
countering that gen Z is going to be
crazy your Alpha is going to be crazier
these kids who are addicted to these
machines who have no sense of family who
who don't know their dads or or haven't
seen their families because they've been
raised by the state when they get in the
vote I think the system just implodes
and you could see now uh it's the
biggest generation of kids that are
still living home in a parent's basement
you know yeah most of not that I'm
knocking that I got a son that still
live at home that many uh economic
opportunities compared to what people
had before financial situation you know
I was in business by the time I was 19.
I moved out when I was 18. I was rocking
and rolling like in New York how old are
you 56 56. so is it what is that Gen X
or is it Boomer I couldn't tell you one
of the two it's like might be might be
I'm on the cusp maybe I got both 57 57
was that the year you were born 56 66 66
yeah so I think that's I think that's I
think that's a that's a more generation
earlier early early oh you're late
Boomer like maybe I'm a boomer I don't
know that well so you you see what the
the Gen Z the meme okay Boomer like
dismissive of this they're growing up
you're seeing a lot of socialism why
these kids don't have jobs they go to
school at school you're told what to do
don't push back we give you your food we
give you your books then they go to
college these are these are young people
who never had a job I'm not saying not
like every gen Z person has never had a
job I'm saying there's a generation
in this generation is a large swath of
young people they're now 22 years old
getting out of college and never worked
a job in their lives how are they going
to enter the workforce they can't they
end up going to places like Twitter
where they walk in and have red wine on
tap and they go to the Lego room where
they can do building blocks then they
have the meditation room because they're
just so stressed out and they think
these mean words on the online are pure
violence yo I'm not I'm not excited
about where this country is going
because we're losing the the generation
that are like I started a business when
I was 18 and we're gaining the people
who are like I went to school till I was
28 and don't know how to and it's pretty
amazing that everyone I grew up like all
my good friends we did one of them went
to college became a pilot but all the
others are like ones in construction
one's in tile one's a contract the one's
in the jewelry business we all did very
well for ourselves and I'm hoping that
it continues but you're not really
seeing it like you're saying I'm not
hopeful I mean do the people my peers
they're always complaining they don't
want to work they're unmotivated they're
lazy and they're sad
it's it's
yeah I'll tell you I live on a ranch out
in Oregon and there there's this one
college I respect the I have these
neighbors these kids they're about 30
years old about your guy's age and they
all went to this Oregon uh Technical
Institute in Klamath Falls and they all
came out with a profession once a dental
hygienist the other one does sonograms
then in this all engineers and they're
all good kids man they were all
conservative kids they're not on their
phones like I hang I hang out with these
kids that down the street and they that
they're just really good solid kids so
it gives me some hope but they're so
outnumbered these kids and they all are
working or doing something they're all
and they all got great professions from
this one college but they're in the
they're in the minority right speaking
up and speaking out is a key uh it
requires a lot of I mean it's you could
argue like LOL is that really that much
work you're on a TV show talking but
like you know physically I'm not ex I'm
mentally exhausted but we just need
people to be honest in public the more
people from Gen X that are honest in
public I blame my own generation I see a
lot of my old friends from high school
just like floating just waiting until
they die basically enjoying the fruits
of what our grandfathers did for us yeah
well you know Klaus Schwab said you will
own nothing and you will be happy that's
the plan that they have implemented
that's essentially what where we're
headed towards and the society that
we're we're at but people aren't happy
they're just drugged up that's the point
they're making marijuana legal
everywhere that can't be helping all
these kids smoking weed every day
overdosing if any drug is a problem
alcohol too that's okay one that's
Insidious in our society I think South
Park put it uh really well when they
South Park did an episode on pot and
then uh it was actually funny it's they
hired this company where people pretend
to be their kids from the future and
their their drug addled losers who are
like you don't want to smoke behind me
and look at me and then you know the
kids are not stupid and they're like
this is ridiculous we don't believe it
then at the end Stan's dad says look we
just don't want you smoking marijuana
and he's like why don't you just be
honest with me and he's like well son
the truth is
marijuana makes you okay with being
bored and then when you're older you'll
find that you're not good at anything
and that was just like the simplest
explanation of when kids are out
partying and drinking it doesn't matter
if it's pot or anything else without
Direction without discipline without
stability they end up you know as young
adults with no capabilities so they have
no Mission they have no Drive they have
no skills and they're angry why can't I
buy that new car why can't I get a nice
why is life so hard for me and it's like
well you spent your teenage years doing
nothing you know for for the people who
are successful like you you said you
started you were in a business when you
were 19. yeah well I don't know what
what's the answer then you guys are
younger than me what are we going to do
family generation uh family religion
maybe I've been thinking a lot about
finding peace with the past that's a big
part of it for everybody for people in
general just fine accept what happened
and then prophesy good things for the
future because sometimes what we'll do
is we'll look at the past and then say
because that happened because there's so
much it indicates that it will happen
again but we are basic we are offering
our versions of the future to the world
so you know Tim mentions religion and
there's one thing I I I'm in a circle
with some religious Jews there Chabad
and my rabbi's a Chabad Rabbi they
really do something right they they
honor the Sabbath so every Friday which
is great for the family I I wish I did
it with my kids so everyone should do it
Friday come Sundown they shut everything
down the phones the TV everything all
the family gets together Friday night
they pray they have a big dinner they
have some drinks they chill out all the
way till Saturday Sundown how much
better would Society be if every family
did that you know what and it's really
one diet several years and what else is
this is what a lot of people attribute
to a lot of the success uh you know so
most epic things about Islam is fasting
I I've been looking into the tenets of
Islam there's five pillars and one of
them is Ramadan it's this month-long
scorching heat Ramadan means scorching
heat when they lived in the ninth month
of the year like September and they just
had to live under the burning Sun so
they were fasting to survive because if
you eat in the burning Sun you're gonna
burn and uh now in solidarity with those
that did it to survive people will Fast
for a month straight but man clearing
out your gut because like you were
saying earlier Luke it's another type of
brain and it will get closer yeah and
it's being ruined uh you know
deliberately I think that's a fantastic
offering from Islam is fasting one of
the things that we've been working on is
uh I call it Saturday morning cartoons
there are a lot of people that don't
have that Sabbath where Friday night
they stay with their families and they
have dinner and there's a lot of people
that don't go to church so what we want
to do is Saturday morning we got it we
got a new location we're setting up it's
gonna be a public uh we're gonna do Cafe
on the first floor games and stuff uh
skate shop maybe second floor and uh
Saturday morning you come in you bring
the family and the kids will watch
cartoons that are not degenerate or you
know like they'll be normal fun watch
bugs Bonnie you know like I don't mind
Bugs Bunny show show Elmer Fudd walking
around with a double barrel you know
trying to hunt ducks or whatever I got
no issue with that but there's there's
cartoons that I think uh kids could
watch I mean the stuff I grew up with I
think uh in the 90s wasn't so bad but
now you got really really weird stuff
like uh Blues Clues had like one episode
where it showed a beaver with double
mastectomy scars and like you know so so
we want to create a space where parents
can come in the morning everybody can
meet each other people who live nearby
can become friends we can build
community because the reason I say
religion is not because I think you know
I'm not an overly religious person I
don't think the solution necessarily is
that people need to find God people need
to find each other religion is one
method ISM for that when people used to
go to church they'd be with their
Community once a week they would talk
with each other they would learn what's
going on in the community with uh with
Shabbat dinner you've got families
sticking together cutting everything out
saying no no we're here together as a
family strengthening the family unit all
of that leads to success family that
prays together stays together that's
true always hard to hurt that have you
been absorbing any of the Shabbat
goodness yeah I really love it uh
whenever I'm in town I go to my rabbi's
house uh and I just shut it down you
know a lot of times my sons will come
with me and we'll just sit with the
rabbi and he talks gives you a little
Torah uh something you know he'll give
you a Torah story and I have a rabbi in
uh Ashland when I go when I'm in Oregon
that'll hit up his house or the temple
once in a while for the holidays but
it's important they always stay in touch
with me uh we built through my
Foundation we built two playgrounds so I
was able to raise money and we built the
playground in Florida and Coral Springs
at the temple and I built one in Ashland
also what do they look like just cool
little playgrounds for kids to play and
have fun you know like swing swinging
ropes and stuff yeah if we got a slide
you got a swing you got something you
know the kids hit the drum you know they
love all that stuff but through my
Foundation of raising money we were able
to do that for the temples and I enjoy
going I think it's like Tim mentioned a
few times it's very important a family
staying together and doing things like
that even if you know not so much
religion but it's the getting together
and just being with your family this is
why I think they shut the churches down
during a code pandemic Walmart was
allowed small businesses weren't
churches weren't Parks not Florida
though they shut down the playgrounds
my Rabbi made sure to thank them when we
were at a rally recently uh with the
governor and uh my that was one of the
biggest things what my Rabbi was so
happy and to thank the governor for was
keeping the place of religion so people
could come and pray it meant a lot to
him and he wanted to make sure he
thanked the governor people don't
understand how big that was especially
when huge even the federal government
was saying you got to lock down what
Sweden is doing is wrong and that was
from the Trump Administration which was
absolutely insane so I I think truly
with so much pressure from the federal
government from the corporate media on
Florida specifically there was other
states that also didn't lock down but
specifically Florida was where everyone
was pointing to criticizing saying this
is going to be the bloodbath they're
going everyone's gonna be dead here
everyone's gonna die they have such a
big elderly population it's it's a given
everyone's dying here DeSantis is a
murderer and the Santa said no I'm gonna
not bow down to your emotional extortion
and I think truly it was Florida
standing up against all these pressures
that allowed the United States to not be
as Draconian as a lot of people planned
it to be and what was interesting all
the people from the Northeast that moved
down to Florida and I'd say turned out
voting Republican as you saw in the
election he won like 20 basis points or
something like that like a record right
he won by yeah I relocated there I moved
down to Florida because yeah my
residencies in Florida I'll never give
it up yeah oh so yeah you go back and
forth back and forth but majority I'm in
Florida and that's where I vote that's
the first thing the governor asked me
when you see me he didn't change
residency did you go no don't worry Iran
I'm voting for you you got it you know
we had a dolly form it was great
double-digit Victory what did he win by
a million votes 1.5 or 1.6 was like we
almost got stuck with that other guy
Gillum if you guys remember yes caught
in a hotel room yep naked gay
prostitutes and drugs he almost won it
you know that's how terrible it was
Florida it's amazing how Florida went
from being a swing state to so Republic
it's so red it's one of the right
Estates everyone that in the state
that's running something that's
Republican so there's
um I'm gonna I'm gonna butcher this so
uh Prager I apologize what is it cut
flower politics I I think he calls it
was that what it was I think so yeah he
says that um you have this beautiful
flower in a pot and then you pick it and
hold it up and show how beautiful it is
but then as it's been separated from its
roots it slowly Withers and dies and
that's what we're dealing with now as a
society we
I feel like right now we don't realize
the wave has already hit in this country
as as we believe it doesn't exist
anymore we talk about the FBI they
they're seemingly only going after
enemies of their of their tribal
ideology so a garage Paul rope 12 agents
but uh someone's you know a bunch of
people showing up to the Supreme Court
Justices Holmes illegally protesting ah
we're not getting involved in that
pro-life activists however gotta track
them down lock them up January 6 two
years solitary no trial mass shooting
still like shootings they dropped the
bull I mean look at that there's a meme
of from a member remember on The
Simpsons episode where Bart says was it
woozle wazzle or something like that no
no no I didn't do it is that what the
line was I don't remember but he gets a
catchphrase and then all the students
look and turn to him and they say say
the line Bart the meme is he goes it's
like he's got the FBI hat and he goes
the suspect was known to us and we took
no action and then they're like Yay
because it's happened so many times we
could only hope that the house now could
do something you know maybe they'll look
into it because if they don't know who's
going to do it even the Department of
Justice you know they're all they do
whatever they want well this is the
issue the reason I bring up The Cut
Flower politics idea
the flower is dying and there's no
reattaching it to the roots it's not
going to happen I think you can slice it
back on okay come on okay I'm talking
about a political metaphor trying to be
positive
uh sure sure no I mean to be to be
Perhaps Perhaps there is a way to
reconnect with our roots and that's
actually a good way to put it so I
actually uh I stand corrected if we can
restore Our Roots and get back to what
made this country function better maybe
we can turn things around I think
there's a good opportunity for that but
right now what I see around us
well actually you know maybe you were
completely right what I see around us is
is a light at the end of the tunnel with
the with the Republicans taking the
house this may be the point where we
start turning things around if more
shows like this more more people like
Crowder more people like stick sex and
Hammer more shows pushing through the
noise more people able to counter The
Narrative Elon Musk taking over Twitter
that was great this is this is a
potential opportunity to start rejecting
societal collapse and degeneracy and
saying there's got to be some degree of
responsibility
meritocracy uh protecting the family
maybe maybe we actually are restoring
those things
I was thinking I like this metaphor
about when was the when was the flower
cut was it the Federal Reserve Act 1913
Woodrow Wilson did he slice no was it
the 90s because Reagan was awesome I
remember Reagan was pulling down the
Berlin wall and like ending the Cold War
it's it's the 2000s and I think it was
social media that was the internet yeah
the internet algorithms algorithmic
manipulation uh and the financial
collapse these things all happened right
around the same time but didn't you guys
feel that we got a little reprieve when
Trump won like I thought the country was
going it was so horrible 2016's the
first time I voted you know I just
couldn't I had to get involved and vote
the way the country was going like it
was now it's just no like no different
from when Obama ran things from when
Biden's running things there's two ways
so I thought that you know him getting
elected I thought you know patriotism
look there's no patriotism now in this
country he brought back patriotism and
the country was definitely doing a lot
better then than it is now there's two
ways to look at I guess uh I've heard
these stories about old people on their
deathbed you know they're lethargic
they're dying and then one day all of a
sudden they sit up
tons of energy they're talking They're
laughing they say get my family in here
I'm feeling great and they're like whoa
the family comes in they all share
laughs and memories and then say goodbye
and the next day the person dies like
all of their energy is mustered up for
one last goodbye and I love you that
scares me that idea that the Resurgence
of trump was the last mustering force of
people who care about this country and
believe in the values that made it great
you believe that no I think it's a
possibility but it's also possible that
Donald Trump was a shot of adrenaline
that he was that EpiPen straightened to
the thigh and now where's the country
went
so as we have these bad things still
happening around us we now have the rise
of people like DeSantis we now have the
narrative machine crumbling we now have
Elon buying Twitter far from perfect
this guy Elon but he's releasing these
documents he did more for the for social
media than any GOP the GOP evidence
did to beat the big Tech just recently
private sector yep yeah but but maybe
Donald Trump was we were all sitting
around feeling our heart tighten and
then Trump came along like an EpiPen for
all his faults he was he was a shot of
adrenaline and now the vision's very
clear in all this transparent nonsense
you're like what like the FBI is
directly involved with it I mean we kind
of have the feeling this was going on
screaming it from the top of his lungs
about it for years you know the FBI the
Department of Justice the collusion the
Russian BS you know and it was all it
all came out to be true thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become member
over at timcast.com for uncensored
members only shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time